i want to start today with firings and
resignations over refusal to get
vaccinated at a variety of different
employers
but specifically within health and
hospital systems we talked about this on
the bonus show a little bit earlier in
the week and we're going to dig into
some more details jeremy actually sent
me um a a couple of links here that i
think are interesting to look at from
becker's hospital review about what's
going on in a number of different health
systems let's review 1400 unvaccinated
workers leave northwell health
a total of 1400 employees of new hyde
park new york based northwell health
either resigned or were terminated for
refusing to get vaccinated against covet
19 confirmed by a spokesperson
the departures announced one week after
new york state's mandate took effect
requiring healthcare workers get at
least one shot by september 27
included about two dozen leaders at the
management level
or higher and represent under two
percent of northwell's employees
with the departures northwell is now
reporting a 100 percent vaccinated
workforce this is as it mentions in the
article a 23 hospital system
and the largest health care provider in
new york state 76 000 employees
and one of a few that have terminated
workers for choosing not to get
vaccinated so
fourteen hundred is a very big number
at the same time it's under two percent
at the same time
that still at close to two percent is
much higher than the one half of one
percent to one percent number that we
previously thought about as a likely
outcome for many of these requirements
okay continuing kaiser suspends 2200
unvaccinated employees kaiser permanente
has placed just over 2200 employees on
leave unpaid as of october 4 for failing
to comply with the system's covid19
vaccine requirement
kaiser announced the vaccine mandate in
early august gave employees and
physicians until september 30 to become
fully vaccinated for covet 19 or apply
for medical or religious exemptions 78
percent of the system's employees and
physicians were vaccinated as of august
2nd that's now more than 92 percent
the suspended employees make up less
than one percent
of the nearly 240 000 person workforce
the number of employees on leave is
declining as more and more workers
comply
employees have until december 1. so we
previously talked about this issue of
fired or unpaid leave unpaid leave makes
it easier for the employees to get back
into compliance and more quickly come
back to work
which sounds pretty good it's obviously
from the standpoint of the employer
easier and cheaper to retain someone
than to go and hire someone new
it also probably from the perspective of
the employee if you just get fired and
now even if you go and get vaccinated
you've got to reapply or do you look
somewhere else if you're just on
unpaid leave it's as simple as you go
and get vaccinated you can go back to
work it seems better for both employee
and employer and it does seem to be
working there they're at about one
percent uh non-compliant so far fully uh
confirmed non-compliant
and then at another health system 400
henry ford workers leave their jobs over
the mandate
this is the detroit-based henry ford
health system
employees who left their jobs
represent about 1
1
of the 33 000 person workforce
about 1900 workers got exemptions from
the vaccination mandate
more than 30 000 are vaccinated
they say all things considered we're
losing a very small segment of our
workforce i quite frankly wish that was
zero but it's not said bob reiny
president of health care operations and
coo
but it's a very small percentage and our
new higher process is already offsetting
the folks who declined to be vaccinated
and resigned so
all in all pretty good
pretty good when you look at the
percentage uh one of the big success
stories on these mandates and
requirements
is united airlines united airlines is
now this is already this is as of last
week actually i looked for newer numbers
and couldn't find them so this is
already a week old
but
united was down to only 320 unvaccinated
people left they were at 593 at one
point now down to 320.
that's out of 67 000 employees that is
about
half of one percent and continuing to go
down uh the combination is 96 percent
just got the vaccine
2 000 saw exemptions
and they were as of a week ago down to
320.
this works this works and as we've said
before
most people
want to stay in their job i was going to
say most people like their job that i
don't know about that's a little more
complicated but most people
see the value in staying in their job
and at the end of the day
it's just an additional vaccine of the
many that may already be required it is
not constitutionally problematic
problematic it is not legally
problematic it is not morally
problematic it's just the right thing to
do
and i think that i mean listen by sheer
math
over time the number of resistors will
go down either because they uh quit
or get fired or get vaccinated or some
get an exemption so i think these
numbers are going to continue to improve
and uh
by definition places are getting 100
percent into compliance with their own
policies you can say the except that the
exemptions keep it short of 100
vaccinated technically you're still in
compliance if you get a valid exemption
some states allow religious some don't
some states allow moral objections some
don't uh california is very very strict
as far as the exemption exemptions go
but if you look around the country
what we seem to be seeing at large
employers is that anywhere from
half of one percent to on the top end
two-ish percent just shy of two percent
are refusing to get vaccinated 98 99 and
99.5 vaccination
at uh at the population level would
really solve this pandemic of course not
everybody's eligible yet but getting to
that point at big corporations is a
really really big deal one of our
sponsors is called privacy privacy is a
totally free service that i've been
using for years
privacy lets me create virtual credit
card numbers with one click and when i
use the virtual credit card the money is
taken out of my bank account you can
create multiple cards delete them freeze
them set a spending limit on them let's
say i'm signing up for a free trial and
it requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual credit card number
and then after signing up i can delete
that virtual card so i know i'm not
going to be charged again something
really useful and very practical or
let's say i'm ordering food over the
phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video